vou deixar vocês superbonita grande
tratamento é o nosso vídeo de hoje é
como tirar essa cara de lagartixa
a gente acorda desse jeito mas a gente
em poucos minutos consegue
agora quem fala estocar ajudante
lagartixa ó já foi embora sob decreto
vamos usar aqui é henrique a minha mãe
pronto esse foi o primeiro vídeo de
maquiagem da minha vida amigo é tenham
lançado tem muito mais
hoje já não está mais com cara de
lagartixa né tá mais pra leão que o
exercício está um lenço nunca mais será
um imenso para quem passou pelo câncer
um símbolo de elegância e glamour pode
ser uma das nossas maiores armas para
enfrentar o tratamento de uma doença tão
temida aos 31 anos quando fui
diagnosticada com câncer de mama
descobrir podemos ser a melhor versão de
nós mesmos
primeiramente para nós e depois para os
outros
descobri também que são os responsáveis
pela nossa vida
pela nossa saúde e pela nossa cura sabem
aquele momento em que a aeromoça antes
do avião levantar vôo nos instruir por
aqui no caso de despressurização da
cabine quando cai àquelas máscaras de
oxigênio
devemos colocar primeiramente em nós e
somente nos outros que precisam da nossa
ajuda
essa é uma metáfora que eu gosto de
levar para a vida
se não estamos bem com nós próprios não
podemos estar bem para mais ninguém
depois de um tratamento que inclui
quatro cirurgias fertilização com o
congelamento de embriões pois o risco de
ficar infértil
o número após a precoce era acima de 60%
ea minha vontade de estar viva era igual
a minha vontade de ser mãe
na menopausa precoce já sei que não
fiquem mais quatro cirurgias e
utilização com o congelamento de
embriões 16 quimioterapia 30
radioterapia e que me fez ficar careca
sem filhos sem sobrancelha sem paladar
sem a sensação da ponta dos dedos das
mãos e dos pés as unhas rochas negras na
verdade quase sem músculos extremamente
cansado enjoada fez com que eu
aprendesse a valorizar a vida de outra
forma a ter um olhar diferente eo
resultado isso em cinco grandes
aprendizados que fizeram com que olhasse
o câncer não como uma doença mas como
uma cura na minha vida
o primeiro aprendizado
eu coloco para dentro do meu corpo todos
os dias
como dizia thomas carlyle há somente um
tempo no universo e ele é o corpo humano
tudo que eu coloco pra dentro do meu
corpo ele se reflete na estética no bom
funcionamento do organismo e da minha
cabeça na minha saúde e na minha saúde
com qualidade de vida
até esse momento do dia
desde que você acordou o que vocês
colocaram para dentro de vocês do tempo
de vocês essa calma calma gente não dá
pra viver em uma bolha não dá eu também
não vivo nessa bolha eu tenho as minhas
escapadinhas principalmente socialmente
mas são pequenas atitudes no nosso dia a
dia que nós podemos fazer que fazem toda
a diferença para a gente ter uma saúde
ou uma doença foram pequenas mudanças
que eu fui fazendo na minha vida que eu
comecei por mudar
foi o meu olhar sobre os alimentos ele
já não são mais um monte de calorias que
engordam aqui mesmo a grécia mas eles
são sim um monte de nutrientes e
proteínas carboidratos vitaminas
minerais e que eles podem ter um efeito
poderoso o devastador no meu organismo
por exemplo um abacate antes o olhava o
abacate com aqueles olhos assim de
terror como olho para um bolo de
chocolate de brigadeiro que eu amo
também mas enfim mais uma modificadores
vazias e o abacate com quase todos os
dias
hoje em dia porque ele é excelente e
nutrientes de gorduras boas de vitaminas
de fibras e minerais para além disso ele
é bom para prevenir o câncer de mama de
próstata de boca e também ele ajuda a
potencializar os fitoquímicos presentes
nos legumes
tal como por exemplo o irmão quando como
uma salada de rúcula espinafre couve
coloco sempre umas gotinhas de limão
porque a vitamina c ajuda a
potencializar a absorção do ferro dos
vegetais e essas combinações mágicas dos
alimentos nós chamamos de sinergia dos
alimentos e ter essa informação faz com
que sejamos poderosos porque aí podemos
saber o que realmente está nutrindo que
não está fazendo bem o que não faz bem
o que é que nos pode ajudar com essa
informação na zona c não nascemos
ensinadas não é lógico mas
nutricionistas nutrólogos livros muitos
livros mas principalmente nós mesmos sem
querermos absorver essa informação e
fazer algumas mudanças no nosso dia a
dia
pelo menos posso deixar uma dica pra
vocês quanto mais colorido foi o prato
melhor pelo menos a chance de fazer
dupla sinérgica e saber que estamos no
treino nosso organismo é muito maior
segundo aprendizado atividade física
vocês todos aqui estão vivos estão
respirando estão vivos
não mexam se mexam se gente o nosso
corpo precisa
não dá tempo de na academia tudo bem não
tem problema
todo movimento é válido fazer a casa
passe ao cachorro subir as escadas ao
invés de pegar o elevador vai trabalhar
de ônibus ou de metrô sai duas três
paradas antes e caminhando todo
movimento é válido e tantas atividades
no nosso dia a dia que nós podemos fazer
nos movimentando que às vezes nem nos
apercebemos se vocês tivessem aqueles
relógios mágicos que quanto à atividade
física diária e que conta os passos que
a gente dá e que são muitos pais
transformam quilômetros quantos passos
vocês teriam dado hoje eu odeio academia
musculação e correr então aí três coisas
que você nunca vai me ver fazendo essa
era eu
dois anos e meio atrás falando com meu
marido que tentava me demover dinah yoga
apenas duas vezes na semana
quando eu ia porque qualquer desculpa de
trabalho sempre é que é ser sempre a
desculpa válida é eu faltava e hoje em
dia eu pratico atividade física seis
vezes na semana me obriga a ter um dia
de descanso e participei da minha
primeira corrida recentemente na
atividade física diária
eu consegui também encontraram um santo
remédio que me ajuda a lidar com os
desafios ser uma pessoa ansiosa
é uma forma de me manter no momento
presente de me focar e de aproveitar
aquele momento ali que é só meu terceiro
aprendizado encontrar a verdadeira
autoestima dentro de mim todos os dias o
que nos faz realmente
felizes sentir fortes e seguras sentir
bem connosco próprios com aquela vontade
de abraçar o mundo
os mesmos ea maquiagem foram duas armas
dos ferramentas na verdade que levarei
para sempre comigo
apesar de ter vencido duas alavancas a
minha autoestima mudou quando o meu eu
interior mudou foi na humildade do
momento mais frágil da minha vida que eu
fui buscar dentro de mim
a força que eu não conseguia ter por
fora mesmo tendo meu marido e minha
família do meu lado foi necessário
perder todas as minhas molduras
estéticas que eu achava que definiam
para ele procurar dentro de mim quem
quer aquela vânia e ainda descobrir como
pessoa e como profissional
voltei a escrever atividades que já
tinha esquecido que eu amava e que desde
criança eu praticava voltei ao
jornalismo profissão que eu tinha
escolhido aos 14 anos porque eu queria
mudar o mundo
me formei como coach também para
melhorar aperfeiçoar o trabalho que vem
desenvolvendo e passei a ter hobbies
diários
fui buscar procurar dentro de mim
coisas que eram as forças que me
motivavam para querer estar viva e
querer estar viva com qualidade de vida
e como propósito que eu estou fazendo
aqui cola que a minha missão
eu descobri que era o amor que me movia
o amor por mim
primeiramente e o amor pelos outros
assim eu resolvi criar o blog minha vida
comigo o projeto social lança da
solidariedade que já em beleza mais
3.000 carequinhas pelo brasil e cerca de
mil em portugal
escrevi um livro que lancei em portugal
e no brasil onde obras as portas da
minha alma para o mundo
quando comecei a receber vários
agradecimentos porque tinha salvo a vida
de alguém por simplesmente fazer com que
as mulheres deixassem de ter medo de ir
ver o que era aquele caroço que elas
tinham lá não ia porque um médico não
dói mas também não assumia e muitas
descobriram que estava com câncer
eu descobri que eu tinha encontrado uma
missão na minha vida e que eu não podia
voltar à minha
vida passada de executiva o quarto
aprendizado desintoxicar a minha vida
já falamos aqui de cuidar do corpo por
dentro e por fora mas não é só através
da alimentação ou de drogas que nós nos
intoxicando anos
temos a tendência a esquecer a nossa
mente que ela controla os nossos
impulsos e que deveria fazer uma
parceria com o nosso corpo
o tempo inteiro podemos intoxicar com
relacionamentos e emoções tóxicas e o
fato de eu estar ali em frente a frente
como a doença de vai morrer no modo
normal não morta ali na vida e na morte
me fez refletir também sobre a forma
como estava na minha vida e os
relacionamentos pessoais e profissionais
aí comecei a fazer pequenas mudanças
pequenas análises que eu comecei a ver
que não podia libertar sempre de
relacionamentos que desagradassem outras
situações não podia fazer isso
a grande diferença estava na forma como
lidava com aquelas situações emoções
negativas
aí eu resolvi criar um ritual de sempre
que alguma situação desagrada e que eu
possa ver que está me trazendo alguma
toxicidade eu paro observa que eu estou
sentindo do nome esse sentimento
expresso para mim mesma e veja se vale a
pena compartilhar fazendo com que não
guarde naquela caixinha que a gente tem
aqui dentro e todo mundo tem a tendência
de guardar achando que vai esquecer e
que vai sumir mas não some e um dia a
conta chega esse é um fato que o
aprendizado focar no presente
o aqui eo agora quem é que não está
querendo já dar uma olhadinha no celular
para ver o que está acontecendo nas
redes sociais no e mail ou pensando no
trânsito quando sair daqui para pessoas
ansiosas tomou café da manhã pensando
que vamos a e almoçar pensando que vai
jantar é o pão nosso de cada dia
no entanto nós só vivemos aqui agora não
dá pra viver no passado a viver no
futuro
só isso aqui agora é aqui que a gente
pode fazer a diferença é que a gente
pode fazer mudança é que a gente pode
ser feliz
e focar constantemente no que foi não
poderia ter sido tira o nosso foco do
momento presente
como dizia o outro ituran nunca verá
perfeição maior do que existe agora uma
ferramenta que me ajuda muito a focar no
presente no agora é a atividade física
porque sei quando não estou presente
quando eu me machuco solar o meu corpo
está fazendo exercício de repente
tropesso o batom alguma coisa
o caio e nosso corpo ele precisa do
apoio da nossa mente para que funciona
na perfeição
outra ferramenta que me ajudou muito foi
aprender a meditar
então por isso todos os dias durante 10
20 minutos eu fecho os meus olhos
respire profundamente durante um minuto
e começa a falar o meu mantra os
pensamentos eles vêm e não somem não é
assim de uma hora para a outra
só que a diferença é que eu imagino um
trem passando na minha frente e em cada
vagão eu coloco um pensamento seus
pensamentos vem mas eu não tinha pego a
eles e eles sempre vão seguindo o seu
caminho e focar no mantra me ajuda a ter
essa organização mental ea ser outra
atividade que eu achava não ser para mim
eu achava como o corpo não tinha vindo
com a capacidade de correr e que a minha
cabeça não tinha vindo com a capacidade
de se desligar do mundo durante 20
minutos
agora cheia de racismo sei te falar a
palavra nunca com experiência do câncer
aprendi que corpo e mente tem que ser um
só
tudo o que acontece no nosso universo
mental reflete no físico
quando nós ficamos deprimidos meu seu
nosso cérebro que fica triste deprimido
trabalho
o nosso corpo sente a nossa pele o
estômago os rins o fígado tudo fica
triste fica doente
sabe aquele aperto no estômago da
angústia do momento ruim das borboletas
e quando estamos apaixonadas a mente
sente a melhor do que acontece na mente
e que se reflete no nosso corpo
por isso nós somos responsáveis pela
nossa vida e por tudo o que acontece ao
nosso redor
se tem alguma coisa que nos desagrada
nós somos responsáveis por modificar lá
vocês sabiam que homens solteiros e
viúvos pensar mais a atenção para
desenvolver um câncer do que oscar
a solidão em demasia deveria ser
considerado um cassino hoje não só como
tabaco
o cigarro um auxílio de vida nós somos
seres sociais e precisamos de amor
quando um paciente ele encara o
tratamento do câncer com negatividade ea
se sentindo uma vítima
as células dele começam a ficar mais pra
baixo a imunidade não se recupera também
já quando um paciente encara de frente e
vou lutar esse maldito não vai me vencer
assim vencer não vai ser por falta de
esforço meu as células viram verdadeiros
soldados que vão combater muito melhor
do a doença que tiver dentro de nós
eu sou prova disso primeiramente comigo
e depois quando eu comecei a doar lenços
e explicar para as pacientes que ela
tinha um trabalho muito importante na
cura delas tinha um trabalho de casa e
simplesmente se cuidarem através da
alimentação da beleza e da cabeça e
foram aumentarem autoestima
aí eu comecei a receber relatos tanto de
pacientes como enfermeiras que assistiam
às minhas palestras e workshops que
algumas pacientes estavam mudando a
postura delas estava fazendo com que os
resultados fossem muito melhores
esses resultados como é que eles são
medidos antes de nós fazemos uma
quimioterapia em cada uma das sessões é
retirado sangue vai ser analisado e para
ver como está nossa imunidade nosso
glóbulos brancos leucócitos no troço luz
para ver se estamos fortes o suficientes
para levar com mais uma dose de remédio
e aí comecei a perceber esses
testemunhos que começaram e levar também
a minha autoestima e você não posso
parar com isso realmente é um trabalho
que é muito importante a gente levar
para todas as pacientes de todo mundo
tem que saber então resumindo 5
aprendizados cuidado que eu coloco para
dentro do meu corpo atividade física
diária
mesmo que seja com os movimentos do dia
a dia e encontrar o verdadeiro
autoestima todos os dias dentro de mim
vim tocar a minha vida e focar no
presente
o aqui eo agora a vida é como ela é
nós podemos complicá lo ou tornando mais
simples
não espero chegar
momento de desespero para fazer mudanças
na sua vida
comece hoje mesmo pensando em pequenas
mudanças que possa sustentar no seu dia
a dia
nada contra as grandes mudanças mas são
as pequenas que a gente consegue
sustentar e levar o nosso dia a dia
fazem grande diferença
com a mudança vocês vão começar hoje e
amanhã
muito obrigada e um beijo enorme no
coração de cada um de vocês